pues bien hasta aquí ya hemos sacado por
fin la expresión del volumen de este
sólido de revolución que yo tengo aquí
ahora lo que yo voy a querer hacer en
este vídeo es resolver toda esta
expresión y por fin encontrar el volumen
de esta forma extraña que yo tengo aquí
arriba de este sólido de revolución
entonces lo que hay que hacer es evaluar
y resolver esta integral y bueno para
esto lo primero que hay que hacer es
factorizar el pilo voy a sacar a fue el
integral y después resolver estos
mínimos al cuadrado perfecto y que me
queda cuadrado del primero que es 4 y
después dos veces el primero por el
segundo 2 por 2 es 4 por menos de
cuadrada me queda menos 4 cuadrada y
después hay que agregarle el cuadrado
del segundo el cuadrado de cuadrada es
de cuarta bien todo esto hay que
quitarle porque aquí dice un signo menos
hay que quitarle el segundo binomio al
cuadrado perfecto por lo tanto todo esto
le voy a quitar y aquí dice el cuadrado
el primero que es cuatro menos dos veces
el primero por el segundo es decir
cuatro raíz de iu y después de que
agregarle el cuadrado del segundo el
cuadrado de la raíz de qué es
y todo esto todo esto hay que
multiplicarlo por de y para resolver
está integral y ahora lo que voy a hacer
es reducir toda esta expresión que tengo
aquí por lo tanto me queda pi que
multiplica a la integral de 01 de quien
ahora vamos a fijarnos que se puede ir
por aquí
4 - 4 de un se cuenta que este 4 sobre
el negativo entonces 4 menos 4 se van y
después aquí solamente tengo no tengo
nada más lo único que tengo es que puedo
acomodar todo de grado mayor a grado
menor el más grande es de cuarta por lo
tanto voy a poner ya cuarta y después de
sigue ya cuadrada que es negativa
entonces a esto hay que quitarle menos
cuatro veces de cuadrada esto va a ser
para integrarlo mucho más fácil es mucho
más sencillo entonces menos cuatro veces
ya cuadrada y después de que le sigue de
grado mayor es de normal está aquí pero
está lleno mal está multiplicada por
menos no se les olvide por lo tanto hay
que restarle por lo tanto se convierte
en negativa entonces me queda menos
james y después aquí es menos x menos me
dan más es el último término me quedan
más cuatro veces la raíz de ella
entonces
aquí le voy a sumar cuatro veces la raíz
de james y todo esto está x de james
recuerden que estoy resolviendo la
integral por cierto no voy a escribir de
una vez como un medio para que ella
pueda resolver su anti derivada de
manera muy sencilla entonces tengo todo
esto que multiplica de james y ahora si
buscamos ante derivadas resolvamos esta
integral quien es la anti derivada de
cuarta pues es muy fácil le sumamos un
exponente lo dividimos en tres el número
es de quinta entre 5 después antes
derivada de menos 4 y cuadrada pues es
menos 4 y el cúbica entre 3 o menos
cuatro tercios de kubica la anti
derivada o la solución de la integral de
menos a pues es menos ye cuadrada entre
2 y por último la anti derivada de 4 ya
la un medio pues a un medio le sumamos 1
lo dividimos entre ese mismo número el
recíproco de tres medios es dos tercios
por lo tanto me quedan ocho tercios de y
elevado a tres medios y todo esto
toda esta expresión que acabamos de
encontrar hay que evaluarla de 1 a 0 por
lo tanto recuerden primero vamos a hacer
la evaluación en el cuate de arriba y
por lo tanto me queda con nosotros vive
pique
multiplica am y cada vez que yo vea voy
a sustituir a por 1 entonces me queda un
quinto menos cuatro tercios porque
recuerden que uno elevado a la quinta al
cubo al cuadrado y el a tres medios es
uno entonces me queda un quinto menos
cuatro tercios menos un medio más ocho
tercios porque uno elevado a tres medios
también sigue siendo uno y uno por ocho
tercios que quedan criterios ya esto hay
que quitarle la evaluación en cero sin
embargo si te das cuenta en cero todos
se van y qué bueno porque ahora lo único
que tengo que hacer esta operación de
quebrados y que hace el mínimo común
múltiplo de todos estos de 5 3 y 2 es 30
entonces 30 entre 5 y 6 por 16 menos 30
entre 3 es 10 por 440 entonces menos 40
30 entre 2 es 15 entonces le voy a
escribir todo en una vez para que nos
veamos confundiendo a menos 40 30 entre
2 es 15 por menos me va a quedar menos
15 ya esto hay que agregarle 30 entre 3
que es 10 por 8 que es 80 entonces todo
esto más 80 y joel m
apenitas y bueno ya solamente falta
hacer la operación que está aquí arriba
entonces 6 menos 40 15 80 cuánto es 6
menos 40 34 menos 34 menos 15 es lo
mismo que menos 49 en efecto y menos 49
si le sumamos 80 mejor vamos a lo más
fácil menos 40 más 80 es 40 positivo 46
46 menos 15 es lo mismo que 31 31
positivo o negativo no es positivo si
perdonen perdón perdón estaba haciendo
bolas entonces dónde queda 31 y entre 30
es decir 31 30 vos de pin déjenme ver si
no me equivoqué
aquí me quedan 40 46 menos 10 son 46 si
son 46 sí sí sí son 46 y si a esto le
quitamos 15 me queda cuando 46 menos 10
es 36 menos 5 es 31 sí sí sí en efecto
perfecto si sé hacer cuentas entonces el
volumen que nosotros estamos buscando es
31 y entre 30 y ya con esto hemos
con este ejercicio así que nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo